let's talk about vampires vampires -
elephants actually Domo open tomorrow
but the cuteness does not stop with that
cute little elephant those big ol ears
because Tandi Newtons look like daughter
if making her big screen debut is their
set a favorite set of yours day of your
mom or dad's that you've been on and
that you like to visit I went to this
song once that would you a jealous oh
yeah yeah I stole was his listening when
I come over and then Finn and then I
just got back to themes like statement
yeah yeah we can't get over how much
fourteen-year-old Nico looks like her
West world star mama
her dad old Parker is in the biz to
directing movies like the Mamma Mia
sequel my dad I think the main advice
was be nice to everyone because that's
what I remember both of our first jobs
so that can be really daunting when we
got like the entire script that was
definitely quite scary side angle why do
you have a favorite moment probably when
we were doing the fire in the Coliseum
that was not only that that made because
a lot of the girls are very stressed out
this fire we had so much fun because
they were like it would get really hot
[Music]